let me double check
let me double let me double check
okay
hold on
we good
y'all i don't know what the hell just
happened just then
it just kicked us out that's crazy
that's crazy
we back
necromancer
yeah we like your casanti i don't know
what it just did it just did me dirty
that's absolutely sick
i don't get it i don't get it
i guess that's the powers that be right
y'all want to see the intro again
if you want to see the intro again just
hit me hit me i'll throw the intro lord
again
i happen to love the intro
fonza find his way back in everybody
will find their way back in
i don't know what the hell will happen
yo you know what
let's kick it off again man let's kick
it off right
[Music]
uh
ain't no competition in the ring of
cipher cause i'm spitting finally
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
make em pay the piper cause i might go
live like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food production you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussion can i do the custom attitude
michael jackson even got his one and
only homie capping you a phony homie now
you owe me action have him sinking tony
tony tony braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got hands so
i'm ready for the tension i'ma leave him
red you could dance
[Music]
there we go
right back at it
[Music]
there we go that's what we talking about
so damn dude got bears at the time
yeah
okay yo um
music and stuff like that is gonna be up
soon
um talking with artists uh working on
some things uh you see exactly what
we're trying to craft and what we're
trying to do uh the merch is gonna be up
with the combat talk shirts kos uh stuff
is gonna be up
um
new merch in the store is gonna be up
like
it's it's it's it's it's a work in
progress everything's a work in progress
but we definitely gonna get to that
space uh
i'm gonna have the ringtone where you're
gonna be able to listen to the music and
it's it's
you're gonna be able to listen to the
track while you're driving
and i know that beat knocks and i know
that song rocks and i and and i know the
dallas spitting is crazy um
all that stuff works man all that stuff
works
definitely gonna do it garcia versus
tank there we go there we go big bed
stop yo
i'ma tell you
i don't know if garcia this fight tells
me right here if garcia can actually
handle anything that tank gots because
do you think garcia can handle rolly
because when they sparring rolly was
handling garcia
so
he said i re replayed the intro multiple
times that's what's up man
nah nah uh um i own uh well iop owns we
own all our stuff
um so don't worry about that like we
llc'd you know and all of our stuff is
tm then you know we just we got a team
of lawyers if something goes left and i
see something happening and somebody
calls my name to something we'll just
you know put the dogs on
and and
that's it um that's stuff that we don't
worry about um
you know as a business owner i
know those avenues and you know the team
is very coherent when it comes to that
we're very uh
protective of the brand of the stuff
that we do so let me see let me see
oh man what up dragon heart yo be my
dude man yo let me tell you something
i i have been blessed to meet a ton of
people in this community fawn's
definitely one of you necro you you you
was him and automatically dudes and i
don't want to not say everybody but
dragon heart yobe
i can't wait to get to cali whatever so
you know we could break bread bro i
really believe that you're one of uh our
shining beacons in this community
oh we got 21 watching that's what's up
let's get those lights popping let's get
it popping all right so um
we got the fight before the main event
be honest with you uh and
do we want to talk about that or we do
do we want to talk about tank versus
garcia
i think tate pops his forehead off i
really honestly believe garcia
the the animosity tank has for garcia
because of the exposure garcia has
without doing anything in the game and
tank had to come up
you know from the bottom all the way up
to the top to become
a pay-per-view sensation a pay-per-view
draw i think tank really has animosity
towards that it's the same way tito
trinidad had the animosity towards oscar
de la hoya you know even though i felt
that oscar earned his bones but remember
he was the golden one he was the golden
boy he came from the olympics you know
and but the floor the road was paid from
beautiful looks just that in the third
you know and
supreme confidence in fighting
i thought oscar
matured into the person that he he
he is actually
because in the beginning remember he had
that weak chin and he would put himself
into different positions and get dropped
i think ryan garcia is in the same space
i think we have the second coming of
oscar de la hoya what i want is for him
to have the kihones
like oscar de la hoya
oscar wasn't afraid to fight anyone and
i think garcia needs to
stop protecting that o
and go for broke because when when oscar
fought uh julio cesar chavez uh senior
and put that work in
i'ma tell you man i i remember me and
cog
being in a theater on closed circuit
television and i'm sitting around
nothing but mexicans that were going for
julio cesar
chavez and i was going for oscar de la
hoya and you know i don't care what type
of hostile environment i mean he's
mexican as well but remember he's
american mexican and julio is from
kuliakan he's the lion of kulia khan
these dudes is repping them hard so
i was just like in in an alliance pit to
be honest with you so it it it got
really dicey man let me see what's going
on let me go let me
see okay nah um raymond g now i'm not
streaming the match
he said right he doesn't have it he has
psd yeah
yo let me let me tell you the reason why
i think that garcia is the second coming
of oscar if you look at oscar at the
same time at the same age he looks like
him he boxes like him and he moves like
him right
he has a left hook he's fast
uh he has a lot of similarities to oscar
oscar got the extra wrinkle in his game
when he went to floyd mayweather senior
and had floyd mayweather senior teaching
them how to do this the shell you know
and how to how to trap punches how to
catch punches um
when he got away from bob arum and he
actually got trainers that was going to
elevate his game because he knew he
needed other wrinkles because his d
his defense his jaw wasn't all that and
he needed the defense to get him to that
space his offense was supreme oscar
offense was crazy
and if he had floyd mayor floyd
mayweather senior when he fought
trinidad
i think he would have beat my cousin
but the fact that he didn't and he
didn't have that wrinkle in his game
he wasn't going to beat him because
remember he was winning the early rounds
but trinidad just kept coming on and
kept coming on kept coming on and
trinidad you know eeked out the fight to
be honest with you let me see let me see
yes i'm gonna cover the jake paul fight
definitely
okay thank you man uh thank you edge of
the world thank you for following thank
you uh for for tuning in i'm gonna talk
fights i'm not gonna really uh talk
about the prelims to be honest with you
because we're here for the main event
but we're here to you know do a little
bit of fight gossip uh do a little uh
getting to know everybody here
again remember i told y'all drinks is
free drinks is on me so go ahead and
have a drink uh i'm drinking what is
this this is bailey's mixed with a
little bit of hennessy good
a good taste a good taste
but right now we have uh rochelle versus
uh vernon
i think roach is pretty good
i really think roach is pretty good i
really think he's a really good fighter
i think he has a good style
i think he's a a come forward mexican
and he he definitely has power in his
punches so right now rocha is um
he's jabbing his way in and
you know they're in in the center of the
ring actually uh exchanging jabs and a
little bit of right hands not too much
stuff you know
let me see who's that in there mosteka
uh fight night let's go let's go
does garcia want to be an actual boxer
celebrity i think he wants to be both
because
why can't he be both
de la hoya was a celebrity and he was a
boxer right
i know when oscar saw him
oscar saw himself i knew that's how
oscar sold it to him on how to be his
promoter why who else would he go to
to to
teach him how to be who he is
it he he i swear because i was there
from the rise in in de la hoya's whole
career
when i saw garcia i said oh my god he
looks like the second coming of old boy
and de la hoya had a hell of a run a
hell of a run a hell of a fighter he
earned everything that he got in that
ring i mean when he beat julio cesar
chavez the second time i i was like man
this this kid is nice uh he get off the
deck he got checked
his shorts was a little short for me was
a little too short for me but he did
that for the movement of his legs
because he needed to have that that
movement in his legs he always had a
perfect stance as far as his balance
goes um you know he has his legs a
little bit wide look at the difference
between when he had julius caesar chavez
senior
and his i mean um holy caesar uh floyd
mayweather senior in his corner and and
he didn't
you're going to see a huge difference in
style
and positioning and after he got that i
mean yeah he lost to bernard i think
that was a job i think that was a that
was my buddy let me put them over
because they go into business right
after him sugar shane and all that right
yeah okay i mean come on you know fight
is gonna look out for fighters at all
times i'm gonna look out for my man uh
if i'm getting out the game i'm like yo
i'm getting out the game yo let's come
through let me bring you though you
understand it it is what it is
but at the highest height that's why we
want crawford versus spence you know
first of all they don't like each other
second of all
crawford has something that spence wants
and spence wants that last belt
i think
in that fight leading up to that fight
we're going to have a good goal
at it i think spence is going to beat
crawford
terribly in that fight
honestly i don't think it's even going
to be a match
like people think i think it's going to
be a one-way beating because i've seen a
lot of sadistic stuff as far as how uh
spence handles his business inside the
ring i think the way spence
uh goes about his business in the ring
if if he uses bullet he's he's like tom
brady like he he writes down stuff that
you said oh my i like michael jordan you
said this i couldn't do this oh you was
a jordan stopper okay okay and go out
there and embarrass you he did it to
every last person that said something
the last one uh uh trainer said that
they're gonna break spence down and stop
him he said i'm gonna break him and if
his face can hold up to it
oh and it's gonna feel like you're in a
second car accident stuff like that is
detrimental and he
broke uga's ulbru socket broke his nose
uh broke his ribs
he broke us
so
uh spence is a is a terrible beast of a
man he's a beast of a man in that ring
crawford i don't think he's a beast i
think he has a mean edge but i don't
think he's a beast as far as how spence
goes about his business and breaking
people up
oh
god dude what's going on baby
yeah i know i'm talking spicy i know
listen man
if if if if i'm saying something wrong
please check me check me if i'm saying
something wrong give me some facts back
it up because
remember
crawfit got dropped by uh
who who
who was that dude that dropped crawford
crawford
got his chin checked a couple of times
and
crawford i don't think he takes spence
pause
for 12 rounds man i don't think he takes
that type of pressure
i don't i really don't i think and i had
sean porter actually winning that fight
to be honest with you
his corner had sean porter winning that
fight and his corner told him before he
went out there
and so-called knocked him out his father
stopped the fight crawford um uh
porter's father stopped the fight
he his coroner told him you're down
and he
went in there and went to work
so i mean he does what he's supposed to
do
i'm not saying i'm not if if it's any
other fighter i give crawford the edge
it's just this fighter right here styles
make fights
and i think spence is a super determined
type of dude like he's he's a lunch pail
dude like he puts the lunch pill in the
middle of the ring and he goes and does
his business and and
god forbid you have to work with him in
that ring they told him sean porter was
going to dog him out and sean porter was
unorthodox and you can't fight sean paul
to fight
he fought sean porter at sean porter's
fight and broke sean porter up
look when he drops sean porter in that
11th round and he puts his hands up he
looks at him like i told you i was going
to do this to you like spencer's a
different type of animal he comes back
from a car crash and he goes right to
danny garcia now danny garcia is talking
about i wasn't right for the fight
mister excuses don't make excuses after
you get your behind smoke like a
cigarette that smoke like a cigarette
but then you want to make excuses no
this is the dude that should have
excuses the guy that got flipped out of
the car at 100 miles an hour because he
want to drive drunk
let me see
mean machine uh-huh
oh yeah memes yo all right so you
remember now i'm not even talking i'll
talk about gamboa i'm talking about when
gamboa dropped uh crawford i'm not even
talking about me machine so that's two
different people that drop
what do you think earl spence does to
gamboa
what do you think earl spence does to me
machine
and they talking about crawford is this
second coming you the second coming of
nothing like you the second coming of
getting his butt smoked like a cigarette
this
he's literally gonna put him out like a
newport it's going to be horrible he's
going to try to run for a couple of
rounds but i say after four rounds you
ain't gonna be there
the same way
uh
uh um
earl
got peterson
i think he does the same exact thing
everybody's all hyped up for what he did
to a broken down beat up kell brook
kell brook was already smoked
after you know else earl spence was
finished with him he was already done
he's already mailed he was already
signed sealed and delivered
you know that was just that was nothing
come on man and he was putting some work
in on crawford too early on
not saying that crawford ain't that dude
it's just that one dude that he got a
fight that's why that well the fight is
signed now they're supposed to fight in
november
hmm
i can't wait to november
that day i think i'm gonna have a bottle
on my way i think that day y'all gonna
see the versace roll because it's gonna
be nice and cold so i gotta have on the
versace robe and bow my way i'ma pop
that bottle right there cause that's a
hell of a fight that's uh a generational
fight that's that's something
that you celebrate that's something that
you tell your kids yo man we witnessed
history like we we witnessed you know uh
sugar ray type
excellence you know in that fight not
saying that this dude is gonna be like
sugar ray i actually i think crawford is
gonna be like cigarette but um
i honestly believe the earl
earl is that guy man
he's just that strong
hagler guy man
and and i thought haggler beat uh sugar
ray to be honest with you and that's
what made um
haggler disgusted with the sport
and he had to go live in france let me
see kell burke was smoke when triple g
broke him down
he was smart when he fought triple d he
went up to get the bag from triple g
he fought the bigger stronger dude
and
it his face couldn't hold up he took too
many shots to the face
remember earl broke the opposite side uh
orbital bone
not the orbital bone that was broken by
triple g he broke the other side of his
face
okay
so you got to know what type of man
you're dealing with and remember he was
kell brook's size
triple g was bigger triple g was a
middleweight
kell brook is a water weight he went up
there and he went to test his luck i
mean
triple g said go back downstairs and
fight those people in your weight class
before i break your face again
covet
who's better twin boxes jamella
all right jamella jamal who's the better
boxer
if you would have asked me this probably
three years ago i don't want with jamal
jamel has
leaped over his brother
jamelle because remember jamel has the
loss
right and
ever since that loss
uh
derek james is trainer
got him focused
and and i think
jeremel
going to get all those belts has
accomplished more
and fought some very stiff competition
do who has the best highlights i think
jamal has the best highlights
could you imagine being the parents of
those two kids
that are excelling at the highest level
of of of the sport
or their names are synonymous with
excellence
could you imagine the pride as a parent
to have those two kids i'm glad you you
brought that whole conversation up to
which one is better because it depends
on what you're looking for but who's
more accomplished at this moment right
now
is uh jamal i mean jamel
if jamal would have got the fight
with triple g if he would have got the
fight with canelo
um he's not going all the way up to
fight david benavidez when he could
fight these guys here
but everybody that they did put in his
way that was in his weight class
he he washed him
he's he's he has to he has to take the
step forward uh i think the seki the
sadeki fight that he's supposed to have
next i think that fight is actually
going to be pretty good and we're going
to see exactly where he's at but we saw
more of jamelle than we've seen of jamal
lately and that has to change
jamal has to step put his foot on the
gas
who i got ryan fortuna jamal has been on
this beautifully obvious we here that's
right bladex was good um 40 people let's
get those likes up 41 let's go um
i got i got garcia
but can i see fartoona dropping him yeah
i could see fortuna dropping him i could
see fortuna dropping him and
garcia has to just
stop thinking
i think his problem is when he thinks
when he wants to be he wants to be the
celebrity likes somebody in the chat
said does he want to be a boxer does he
want to be a celebrity
um and and i said he wants to be both he
wants to be pretty and knock you out he
wants to be uh gorgeous and knock you
out he wants he wants a stylish hook to
knock you out he envisions
the home run
he's not derek jeta right derek jeter
envisions a double that brings tino
martinez in
to win the game
it's it's it's a difference in the
mentality of the athlete right
whereas um i think a person like barry
bonds
later on in his career envisioned
a home run
as as the win right so i think ryan
garcia right now has to understand
sometimes you have to settle for a bunt
or double to to bring it home
and
when he gets that when that clicks in
his head that he doesn't have to live on
social media and he can live in this
sport that any punch can end you can
really put you in a wheelchair for the
rest of your life
um
and he understands that this this is
very serious because i and he knows it's
very serious he's been doing it all his
life
when he separates those two from the
showman to the boxer
and just cares about that boxing i think
you can see the most dangerous uh
version of uh ryan garcia
that's when he gets that king ryan
gosling because he got king ryan garcia
now i'm kind of
skeptical on that king stuff don't be
don't be throwing king don't be throwing
king on your name if you not that dude
if you not that guy to throw those bowls
like that i mean yeah you had some
knockouts with some uh
cab drivers and stuff like that and you
know uh
delivery dudes
bro
you got to fight those dudes to be that
guy tank can run around with it if tank
wanted to call himself king then tank
can call himself king
tank can do stuff like that you know
ryan needs to earn that space he needs
to get there let me see yeah prince ryan
definitely definitely prince ryan right
now he didn't earn that we got 49
watching let's get those likes up um
it's definitely going to get crazy
right now we still
at the prelims they showed they had they
got the gloves on they're get about to
come out they're right after this fight
right here
and and it's gonna be something dope um
do
let me let me see a one in the chat if
y'all think it goes the distance
let me see a 200 chat if you think it's
going by k.o
if you're gonna make him do boo-boo on
himself
verge brizzle
thank you dead proof that's right
all right dad proof one
he's yeah he done duck so many fights
that's right
that's right two two two two two two
there we go there you go a lot of ones a
lot of tools all right all right so
y'all think we're gonna be sitting here
for a long night i hope it's a short
night my wife cooked man food ready
though
51 in here let's go let's get those
likes up let's do it
hey hey you new in here let me know what
you sipping on if you're new let me know
what you're sipping on and if and if and
if you don't sip let me know what type
of water you do because i like perrier
you know i like to sparkle and water
myself
i like it with a little chill you know a
little with a little wit a little chill
no ice because that defeats the purpose
of having sparkling water don't put no
ice in my sparkling water i want it
separate unless the sparkling ice water
that's ice that's what's up let me see
let me see
king ryan has knocked out some of the
best cab drivers
wine oh who got that fuji see mac what's
going on
tap water do a filter that's what's up
you all crazy he said tap water through
a filter i get my wife ty water should
punch me in the nose
it'll be a situation she'll hit me like
tank that'll be a situation it'll be a
situation
let me see let me see let me see
hazy little thing ipa ooh
got that half-life water there we go
that means that life life water to
half-life
that you make from a work
oh
you make water
wait a second bladex what are you
talking about
oh moet ice oh my god
oh wait a second bristle you got fatuna
oh you know what i'm just automatically
assuming
you dudes is picking ryan
who's picking for tuna
yo who's picking for two let me see a
one if you pick him for tuna let me see
you two if you picking ryan
who's picking for tutor who's who's out
here trying to get the cash grab
let me see
he turned wine into what are you
ridiculous
uh oh
all right
don sir oh
one oh
yo
you don't like ryan cause he runs yeah
yeah true
he said what kind of narcotic is he on
go big or go home there we go
oh you're just still oh you're operated
distilled oh that's what's up
that's what's up so you know water like
everybody like you like you know water
like no other you you you probably go to
water testing places too like nah your
water's not up to snuff we have to shut
you down
javier mccain what's going on
do i think ryan is gonna walk through
for tuna no like i said i think um
petunia's going to drop him
how he deals with it after that uh and
gets up and and stop thinking
and fights
i i think that's what happens
i mean would that be the best thing for
him yeah
but he was in the house just go let's go
also to all my haitians stop i say
yeah it's a water connoisseur
i'm i'm pretty sure he is a water
connoisseur if you work in a distillery
and then
you got to make sure that everything's
up to snuff i mean please huh i'm gonna
give everybody the benefit of the doubt
whatever job that you got i'm pretty
sure that you're gonna be the best at it
so i'm gonna respect it and give you
that credit without even knowing it and
and trust and believe i think i i always
think of the best of everybody first
until they show me something different
so if i give you some perrier you better
know it's perrier you better tell me
it's life water
holding you at a different standard
right hey man don't put that pressure on
me bruh
don't put that pressure on me bro i
don't need that pressure like that bro
all right so what round we in we in
seven to ten let's go
it's almost over and then we go get to
the main event baby
oh yeah rocha is uh is is is definitely
uh doing his job jabbing his way in
you know shooting the right hand he's he
works the body pretty good uh i i can't
lie um
vernon is just backing up he's been
backing up the whole fight he's been uh
in a defensive posture throwing a jab
here and there trying to pivot off the
ropes but uh rocha is um
working him in the sense that uh he's uh
throwing overhand rights when he needs
to he's jabbing his way when he needs to
and um he has a high guard
it's it's it's really to be honest with
you i haven't saw anything that
indicates that uh vernon has won any
rounds i think roach has won all rounds
all seven so far
i wish it would would have been an early
knockout so we'd got to the main event
but it is what it is and this is what
we're gonna get
hey how many people think devin haney
does the rematch
uh with cambosis
uh because remember cambosis uh was
supposed to initiate the
rematch clause so how many people think
uh devin haney goes back and fights
cambosis i think um
devin haney is trying to get the fight
with tank but that would require him
to
get rid of all the belts
does devin haney take that position and
drop all the belts
uh to go get the lucrative fight because
remember
when you have these belts
these sanctioning bodies take upwards of
250 grand sanctioning fees for you to
fight
an amount of your purse um
that's why floyd dropped the belts floyd
dropped the belts because he knew that
his
him being the champion
he didn't need the belts he the belts
wasn't he the belts didn't define him he
defined the belt so he ditched the belt
that's why you can see the pedigree
inside
how he's promoting a tank
tank doesn't care about belts he got his
initial belts and he's going on but he
doesn't care about belts he cares more
about the bag and that is trained into
his head so you have to look at who's
training who remember when oscar was um
when i'm talking about training i'm
talking about not as far as training as
uh as a coach i'm talking about mentally
training him in the business teaching
them the ropes right when oscar was uh
teaching canelo i think canelo learned
more from floyd than he did from oscar
because look how canelo fought
after
he lost to floyd
right so
he learned more from that and he learned
more about being the a side and learn
more about uh how to use certain things
to his advantage and that's why him and
oscar separated so and i say that to say
that how oscar is raising ryan garcia up
in the sport even though they may have a
little bit of differences of course
because it has to be some form of
competitive jealousy when especially if
you were a former fighter and you was at
the highest degree that oscar is but
there's some admiration that oscar has
to see in his kid because he sees a lot
of his self and his kid and i'm pretty
sure he's trying to tell his kid not to
fall into the pitfalls that he did but
you understand he's a young man that
needs to learn his way
i honestly
think that
devin haney
drops those belts and goes and fights
tank
i would
take that route i would really ditch
those belts go fight tank
get that bag because win lose a draw
tank doesn't care about the belts
because kate is will drop the belts
anyway because he doesn't want to pay
the sanctioning fees so
win lose a draw you go get a rematch
right and then you go on to the next and
then you build yourself up from there
let's say you split those fights
i don't think devin has enough pop to
keep tank off i think tate walks him
down and knocks him out
i think tank really has a heavy hand
um but i think devin has the ability to
judge distance so
it would be an interesting fight to see
like i would really like to see
shakur stevenson versus tank opposed to
haney
versus tank i think shakur has enough
pop
and has the ability to box i think
shakur
is the most dangerous
out of the three because he's he's the
total package to me
uh and i think tank
is the most attractive
out of the three
and devin haney is the more workmanlike
if he had a little bit more pop in his
punch he he would be
he would be the best one out of the
three but i think shakur edges him out
because they're popping the punch let me
see camposa activated the rematch cause
i think a month ago i think
i think he did but nobody's talked about
it right
yeah it has way too many championships
what happened in good old times when
fighters wanted to fight everyone um
that's when everybody was broke
that's when everybody was broke right
now these dudes can get one or two
fights get a couple of streams and get a
couple of things going and they don't
want that o to go so it's more
everybody got floyd mayweather itis
right
and they think that floyd is excess as
successful as he is because he has that
o in his name because floyd changed the
narrative floyd made you look at the o
and made you hate the o
and you wanted him to get rid of it so
you actively rooted against him that's
when he became money may right money
made made y'all look at the o
like this dude man i swear to god i want
him to take this loss but when he was
pretty boy floyd the o wasn't there and
you didn't care about it the old i mean
always there but you didn't care about
it because pretty boy floyd was going
out and beating the brakes off of every
and anybody that he can get his hands on
but when he game became money made
he became all about the bag and
preserving that oh
so you thought he made you look at it
he's a very shrewd business dude and
whoever was guiding him out heyman
whoever
guided him the exact proper way to to
make y'all see
something that wasn't there and to this
day
everybody wants floyd to get that l they
give him imaginary l's they oh well this
guy beat you for two or three rounds oh
you was losing uh to my donna he was
never losing the madonna right um ever
so
you have to look at the whole
in in his totality
how floyd changed the narrative in that
let me see
yeah he's definitely she is definitely
the most dangerous the fighters of the
ufc now
uh you'll see it's better than she calls
better than tank yeah uh what round
floyd has been about the money
towards the end of the eighth um
quite possibly all right so they're
about to walk out right now ryan garcia
is praying right now with his team
right before they're about to walk out
you know
and listen man that that's you better
pray to god before you go and do battle
right whatever gods that you believe in
you better pray for safe passage in and
out of that ring uh
one blow can change how you your quality
of life
one blow can change your quality of life
if going upstairs is a thing anymore you
know if walking down a block is is a
thing anymore so
you know quality of life guys definitely
all right we got 51 watching we got 41
in the chat let's hit that let's get
that all right so we're at the ninth
round rocha is uh running after vernon
it is what it is
this this is what i talk about the zone
i think the zone has terrible
matchmaking
when it comes to the top fighters
they match the top fighters that they
have after they uh
exceeded uh
their contracts and then they put them
into fight right
so
they don't have a wealth of talent and
they don't go out and fight pvc fighters
and they they very really go out and
fight espn top ranked fighters right so
a lot of times they're fighting in house
and these these fights be terribly
boring early on fights
you have to say eddie hearn is probably
making the best
uh with a bad hand
that he that he can do
but again um you would want rocha to
fight somebody that is a come ahead
fighter or a slick boxer that's going to
stand in front of you type of thing and
they put him in with vernon with he is a
backup box and counterpuncher dude and
it turns into a boring fight it turns
into a fight that it's pretty much uh
rocha dictate and pace uh and vernon
backing up and throwing uh left hooks
right hands and sliding and staying
against the ropes and
it's it's it's not good matchmaking you
gotta as a as a good matchmaker and
remember you gotta remember style make
fights you have to put together the best
fights that look so that means you have
to not just look at the names on paper
you're supposed to actually
see these fighters see the tendencies
and see how they will match and
visualize a fight inside your head and
match make them that way
i think it's uh you know who's really
good at that lou de bella lou de bella
is very good at matchmaking remember lou
de bella uh was the one who had andy
ruiz and he put andy ruiz in there with
joshua i think andy ruiz and joshua
uh
definitely had sparks it was definitely
a matchmaker's dream because you had a
fast hand short prodding dude that can
get in
uh and close the gap and you had a tall
uh strong boxer that can hold ground and
can hurt you with a jab and definitely a
right hand and had uppercuts so
when you see them fighting
they mesh perfectly the mesh world
excuse me so when you got a chance to
see joshua andy ruiz 2 joshua changed up
the formula and made it work for him but
that was perfect matchmaking in the
sense that you were getting you you got
two different styles of fights in the
same individuals
very good matchmaking i think that lou
de bella is um
is a genius when it comes to stuff like
that let me see
you missing the fight masha
oh thank you man thank you thank you
thank you for tweeting that out all
right so we got 46 right now we got 42
likes that's right we up to the last
round
and then we got the main event
i do not think ryan garcia comes out
first round and trying to blast for tuna
out but i think fardona comes out and he
tries to blast ryan i think he goes
straight for prince ryan and he tries to
take his forehead off his body
he should
he should jump on him and make him
realize why he was afraid and why he
ditched the fight in the first place
excuse me
all right so last round
these dudes getting up into the ring
they're about to you know finish it off
at
10 rounds i could have told you me ray
charles and stevie wonder could have
looked at this on paper and told you
12 rounds
and and we not matchmakers
i would have definitely match realtor
with somebody better
but again you know roach is coming off a
big win so
i guess you know you you give them some
food to eat and uh the next fight you uh
you build them up to actually be
available for something else that
happens next you know
oh my god
you guys are in for a treat tomorrow
with uh iron lord's podcast you are in
for a treat
i would
um
how would i think about anthony versus
uh fury i think fury boxes anthony
joshua's head off
i think the only person
that could have beat fury
was wilder
and think about it think about this
right think about this and and if i'm
lying if i'm lying i'm dying right or
i'm flying or whatever
if
fury gets counted out
in that first fight that he got knocked
out in because if he counted he got
knocked out
he doesn't get up
he he gets knocked out he gets knocked
out on a fight right he gets counted out
second fight never happens
joshua actually has so much pressure on
his back that he has to fight while the
wilder knocks out joshua crazy i think
he knocks out joshua in two rounds to be
honest with you
because i think he's gonna land that
right hand at some point in time and
joshua's not gonna be able to stand up
to it and joshua's just his body's gonna
leave the building
but the fact that fury upset the apple
cart and he got the benefit of the doubt
in that knockdown
changed the whole trajectory because i
think if fury makes the comeback he does
some good
does he stick around funny fights
probably stick around for like two
fights fights uh
king kong ortiz or fights ruse or
somebody
everything is different
but being that it went the way it did
wilder
loses
twice
joshua loses twice
these dudes and and wilder comes back at
the end of this year
i think fury is completely retired i
think after that last fight the fury had
i think he's completely retired i don't
know
i don't know i believe i believe he's
retired i have to double check
and then you have anthony anthony is
going to fight usak again
i think you said beats him worse than he
beat him the first time
and i had us going into that fight
um
the fight is over i told you
and
rocha's winning that fight um
honestly
fury has a style
and an and a boxing iq with an educated
jab and a supreme right hand and knows
when to throw the uppercut
the guy is so
we want him to look better could you
imagine
if fury had the body of joshua
how we would view him
if he had the body
of klitschko
or joshua or vanderholyfield even mike
tyson if he had a physique
that matched his iq
and his boxing ability
you would probably be talking about fury
as the greatest heavyweight that ever
stepped in the ring
visually
we will never make that same assessment
because visually he doesn't
look like that
uh i i stopped watching basketball
um
after um carmelo
left the knicks and went to the lakers
uh i'm a huge allen novice and fan i was
huge into basketball then a huge scottie
pippen fan
uh i love shaq
you know penny hard away and stuff like
that those that's the golden era when
basketball was actually basketball when
somebody goes to the hole and in the
playoffs and you throw a forearm charles
oakley style and bust their face open
and teach them don't go down the whole
pulse um
that's that's when i'm a super fan right
now
i don't know it's too many prima donnas
uh too many soft touch dudes
um
so i don't know um
i think if the knicks can become
relevant again i'm a new york dude
so if the knicks can become relevant
again your boy's back son
uh and i think they can if they can make
this trade get those picks out of there
uh
and and keep
and keep uh a couple of the people that
uh are fundamentally what you have to
build around
because i i know the roster and i know a
couple of people and i don't want to get
into a huge basketball talk
that's there um
[Music]
but
just get rid of all your picks
and get this kid from utah
and
start
start the healing back in new york
because
if you win in new york if you win a
championship in new york i'm gonna tell
you this
if the knicks win the championship in
new york
lebron would be on the next train
smoking hair
he would he would
undoubtedly go down as the greatest
thing that ever lived if he ever was
part of a team that won a ring in new
york i mean he's he's probably second to
michael jordan only because of a couple
of things but um he's second to michael
jordan when it comes to that but yeah
he went here he crazy let me see king
stop no fury would never be considered
better than ali
if he had a body
if if
if
fury had a body the connotation the
marketability the name
he
[Music]
you see what you what you what you what
you
how you're viewing it right now
i'm not talking about as far as oculus
you got to look at his accolades too man
um tyson fury has some a very damn good
resume
marketing wise
remember
we are a vain
human species
if we can have that guy look like how we
want him to look and fight like how he
does because he he he fights
he boxes he fights
if you can get him to look like that and
that guy works out man i'm so sad that
you know he just
doesn't have you know the disposition
his body is the physiology is is not
capable to reach
you know what his his skill base is
if he did
the conversation is different brother
don't fool yourself
we are vain
uh obsessed people
and if he looks the part
and he boxes
good god
good
that's how let me tell you why let me
tell you why i can say that
ryan garcia has he won a belt
but he's headlining a card right now
why
because his boxing ability matches his
looks
don't ever forget that part
yeah donovan mitchell
he said i'll quit the gym asap
i think he went from lifting to eating
all right thank you iron lowe's podcast
jason fury has such a technical box and
man if he got chiseled he'd be the goat
king ali was bigger than all of these
boxes without
you're looking at a different time in a
different era and you're trying to
compare the two
right
you're looking
you you you know what it is you forget
when ali was the most hated
when ali wasn't to celebrate it
and i remember when ali wasn't the
celebrator and he was the hated when ali
was jailed
for his um
for his stance
right for the stuff that he he he his
principles his morals stuff that people
wouldn't do now
to be honest with you
um
so
remember what i'm saying i'm talking
from
being in that
space growing up in that space
remembering when the world turned their
back on ali you know why frasier had the
biggest problem with ali
when the world turned their back on ali
joe frazier was the one that picked him
up gave him some bread
picked him up in the living gave him a
fight
joe joe frazier
reached back for his boy
and
ali flipped on him at the press
conference
that's when he was like hey gorilla
we're in manila
could you imagine that if you helped
your boy out your brother out and your
brother turned you
into something he what he what he called
uh frasier
was a uncle tom
that was so damning and so hurtful to
frasier
and in in in the black community that
that was so damning and so hurtful
you cast a prideful
champion
as the villain
in your story and the world gravitated
towards it
why because ali's skills
and his physique
fit the narrative
don't ever forget we are a vain species
and if your skills
and your physique
match
brother
you are king
it happens that way it sucks
you know who's you know who was
one of the complete
uh anomalies to that
butter bean anybody remember butter bean
roly-poly dude that
had no skills just go in there and box
you bop bop
drop you
yeah
he's the outlier
because he had without the internet
butterbean was that guy
yo
don't ever forget that man they're
getting ready to come to the ring right
now for tuna's talking about his um
journey to get there let me see let me
see let me see let me see
yes ali talked to talk and he was a
marketing genius
you will get in the ring with wilder but
won't get in the ring with mike tyson
bro
knockout percentage-wise either one of
those dudes is going to separate you
from your consciousness and you're going
to find yourself uh picking up
everything that you have for lunch and
your teeth at the same time both of them
dudes
look at deontay wilder's wildest
knockouts
so he punched the dude into a seizure
fit
are you crazy
man listen
uh al is here fourth grade addiction
i don't like that what ali said to joe
frazee either man
better being
still disappointed and now leave for the
gorilla comments brother
um the man has passed on i'm not
disappointed i'm into anything
uh
in that era in that time
you know ali tried to make it right with
frasier frazier was a prideful man and
fraser held that in his soul all the way
to the grave man
butterbean was the underdog always hell
yeah but he was knocking dudes out mike
tyson was so scary in his prime small
dude of muscles taking out giants and
stuff like that
yo i could tell you a story about me and
um mike tyson but i wouldn't
until somebody pays me for it right um
but uh me at 18 years old
uh my ex-girlfriend can attest to this
i was a complete savage
i was probably um
superman aaron davis one of my dearest
friends
uh go look him up uh iran barclay one of
my my dearest friends rest in peace
panel whitaker one of my friends
um
man listen
i was a complete savage
i would have actively fought my tyson
very easy
actively for them
in his prime whatever i would have went
in the ring and i would have fought him
actively
actively
and uh if if you get a chance to see
superman aaron davis go ask him you get
a chance to talk to iran barclay go ask
him
uh yeah that yeah i would i would have
gotten ring with him very easily with no
problem
because at that probably at that time
what i was like what what 220 225
me 2 20 20 oh god man serious ryan
garcia is about to walk out right now
he's wearing a chain on his neck this
guy's ridiculous he's a special case
mike was never terrifying to me
nah mike was never terrifying to me
um
because the difference is
mike you're gonna either you're gonna
get knocked out or you're gonna win
right
so once you once you say to yourself
it's and it's always a knockout oh you
out right oh and you up
you know the person that actually
scares you
is that dude that beats you bloody
you know
um george foreman ernie shavers
you know
allie fought some of some serious
savages right ken norton
ken norton is a dude that should scare
you
he has enough power to break your jaw
and enough ignorance to keep you around
ali fought with a broke jaw fighting ken
norton
uh ken norton is a savage that's that's
that's a scary dude to fight
micah separates your consciousness gets
you out of there you and mike at the
club later drinking mimosas
fine
a knockout easy that's gone you gone
mike is not terrifying what you're
terrifying if terrified is waking up
looking at the ref like what the hell
happened here that's the only thing
you're terrified at you're not terrified
at mike running down on you and hitting
you like it's not going to beat you up
yo him and razor runner the only thing
that the reason why razor running look
the way razor running quits because
razor running was too stupid to fall
asleep
excuse me
covey
razor ruddick was too stupid to fall
asleep and mike was so smart that he
kept beating him
ken knowing yup king
calling ea tell him we're a fight night
at
nah
um we were looking at esba something
like that whatever that boxing is right
uh what's that what's that
is oh i thought that was jennifer lopez
up there
i was about to say on god why is she at
the fight now you got sean porter
sitting there sean porter look like he's
trying to become a promoter he got on
his derby hat rolled up at the tip your
man looking sharp as always
and they're getting ready to come
outside and fight now okay yo yo yo my
dude hip hop that's my guy hip-hop game
yo yo hip-hop
much respect for coming through brother
just like everybody here i totally
respect everybody that showed up my man
took the time out to come out and talk
fight that's what's up man hip hop was
good baby everybody show love to hip hop
in the chat um
this this this is gonna be something
decent this is gonna be something nice i
think ryan has a lot of what he needs
to win this fight but i think fortuna
also has a lot of what he needs to test
ryan and i'm looking at this as a test
i'm not looking at at this as oh you
know for tuna is has a 50 chance to beat
him i think fortuna has a chance to test
him and that's what i need i need to see
him being tested i need to see him to
see if he's going to go to that next
level because tank and shakur and haney
is there already they're at that next
level
um is ryan ready for this man and and
and this is this is my hope that he's
ready for this right now so they're
getting ready to walk out right now you
know fortuna's gonna come out first
let me see let me see him seem to see
hip-hop that's what's up and said tank
davis versus earl spence needs to happen
you said tank versus earl spin stop that
man
all right first of all tank too small
for earl
earl would punish tank in a way that
you've never seen in boxing history
take nice but earl will punish him like
a savage man no you mean crawford versus
uh earl spence needs to happen
let me see
now i'm older do you think any of those
guys are scary i feel like i could beat
some of them i'll run free with
everybody stupid hip-hop gamer in the
building speaks facts don't care about
your feelings let it be popping baby
let's go that's what's up man this
there's much love for hip-hop in there
man that's what's up man always coffee's
gonna be taken care of but yeah
definitely javier
definitely all right so you got for tuna
walking down and fortuna looks happy to
be there man um i think this is probably
going to be one of the tuna's biggest
paydays
and i don't want him to look at it as a
payday i want him to look at it as an
opportunity opportunity to make more
money
right um that's what you always look for
stepping stone fighters right how they
looking at it
as all the mortgage and stuff is paid i
could pay off that house is is that how
he looking at it or is he looking at it
like
man this ain't enough
that dude shortchanged me i want more is
he angry is he angry at the fact that he
got to walk out first is he angry that
uh the dude was uh disrespecting him
that's what i want to say i want to see
if he's angry
if he's upset at being second class uh
when it comes to the a side because
remember there's an a side to the record
it's the b side and a lot of times
people feel disrespected when they're
the b side and sometimes that b side put
the beats upon the a side so that's
that's that's what i want to see so
right now for tuna is walking in he's
getting ready to get in the ring and
he's showing his highlights and his
highlights looks kind of swiffy back hey
man
you know whoever running the clips could
make a dude look dope as hell
uh is he a knockout artist nah he's not
a knockout artist uh but he's a former
champion former two-time champion so two
times he walked to the precipice and two
times he came away with those belts so
two times he taught you exactly who the
hell he was so um
let's not forget
you know ryan garcia ain't got no belt
he didn't have one belt did he get to
the precipice yet is he is what he's
supposed to be
let me see planning and use iptv nope
what's up wilder while this should be
coming soon
pause
arrow spence will lose to somebody when
he goes up too high in weight
i honestly believe i i believe he's
shocking these dudes at walter weight
and
his after he beats crawford he goes up
and he fights at middleweight
and
um
or super walt away to or whatever way
cast though the 154 weight class he goes
up to the 154 and and i think they all
move up you know uh you have jamelle uh
goes up and fights at um
at middleweight and jamal goes up to 168
and spence goes up to 154
cleans out the division and tries to get
all those belts
uh while
avoiding uh boots and all the other
dudes just at walter wait uh and and you
you have all the waterway dudes
like danny garcia and all those dudes
going up to one five four and you know
can't get out the way
finally we may get um
uh what's this guy keith thurman versus
spence finally we might get that that'd
be dope i i
i would love that but keith thurman
needs to go up to one five four and get
a belt but he can't go up there right
now because if he goes up there right
now he has to fight jamal jamel and if
he fights jamel i think jamel beats the
hell out of uh keith thurman so keith
thurman has to wait until jamal jamel
goes up and vacates the belts and the
the belts are scattered and then when
arrow goes up earl can go start picking
out belts and keith has to jump on
whoever the weakest link is to get a
belt to actually get that fight
let me see ryan is only about a social
media life this is true what happens
when he does lose the crawfit yeah well
hopefully
you stick around
stick around
i don't i don't see that happening i was
probably one of the only people that had
uh evander holyfield beating mike tyson
anytime they step in the ring if they
fought 10 times a week amanda holyfield
beat him 10 times a week in my opinion
uh it's
i'm a pretty good matchmaker when it
comes to putting styles together and
his style
and the mentality of the fighter
is what i saw when it came to the event
holyfield and the fact that i'm a huge
evander holyfield fan
evander holyfield is probably my
greatest fighter
my greatest box i've i've i've been
there since he won bronze in the
olympics i've i
i love how he fights
and he looks the part
he looks the part you see how i i go
right back to being a vain human being
he looks the part
he looks like he did the work in the gym
he looks like that's something that you
can back
ryan garcia is coming out the trumpets
y'all
he has a uh a crown
on on a lion and he's coming out king ra
uh
boy that might end bad if i told her
beats him oof
that would smell stinky he can't he
can't even do that yo he put himself in
such a position that he can't even lose
the fortunate because if he lost the
fortuna the way tank and the rest of
these dudes would clown him oh my god
the level of depression that he would
have boy that's that's what happens man
social media you build yourself up to a
space
now you got to rock that space
um he said spring water
agreed water what happens when you do
oh okay so you just catching up right
now uh to marshall rules okay
all right so he's coming out the
fireworks
he has a chain on his neck
i guess he a rapper now
he's killing me he's killing me
45 watching let's go
all right so he's walking down
we go we're gonna get to this we're
gonna get to this right now i wonder if
they got to do the national anthem for
him
all right so the guy put his hand on his
back was like hurry up and get to the
ring man cut the crap out and stop
playing around let's go
let me see let me see i see it coming
out like hip hop game i was gonna say
that with the big chain right i was
gonna say that he got the hip hop gave
him slack
i was definitely about to say that
look look look look how slow he walking
look how slow i'ma tell you man
man a lot of times man
i don't think he has the eagerness to
get in that ring
he's standing right there he's soaking
it up he's not walking in the ring
he's actually stopped
walking
he's putting his hands up
he's smiling to people
i
i hope to god he's not having a panic
attack
he's at the top rope man
did he have a crazy interest yeah
he's having
a situation happen right now that's kind
of weird kind of weird for me
i mean the last time i saw somebody do
that was probably prince and i see him i
met when he was at the garden and and
you know
he stopped and he waves his hand but
that's a princeton i've seen her made
thing you know other than when he came
in on the carpet uh and i'm gonna talk
about the time when he was fighting um
uh this guy when he came in on the magic
carpet i'm talking about the time when
you know because he fought in the garden
a couple of times uh when he just come
through and he stands at the top of the
rope and he does that but ryan garcia
wasn't at the top of the rope he was at
probably
10 feet away from the steps where he's
just stopped
walking
and
it was just kind of weird to me i don't
know i i know uh fortuna right now is
here to work uh ryan looks bone dry
all right now when you when you're
saying somebody looks bone dry that
means
was they working in the background
getting a sweat going
and and that's necessary because you get
your muscles limber you get your
reaction time going uh you don't want to
actually walk into a athletic event cold
because you could pop a hamstring you
could twist something you could pull a
muscle anything can happen right and
mentally you want to be warmed up it's
like you jumping in your car i'm pretty
sure that y'all hit the remote start on
your car before you jump inside your car
and you let your car heat up before you
actually drive off now not very really
do you want to jump in your car and do a
cold start anything could happen get
down a street pop a hose or something
like that right
so um
i don't know man ryan garcia doesn't
look
uh
sweaty he doesn't look warmed up
fortunate still has on his shirt
and under the shirt looks a little bit
wet
so
pause um he's taking his shirt off right
now
you know um
i don't know fatuna looks nice
uh
37
and uh three with 26 kos one no decision
one draw
okay
good definitely good record i waited for
this for tuna fight for a minute because
the first time that they were supposed
to fight i waited for this fight and now
that we do get the fight i actually get
a chance to see them in the ring and see
what was going on with ryan at that
period of time
let me see uh what's good everyone hope
all is well what's going on uh dipped
down games and anime what's going on
facts every person on ilp don't come
in to the debates bone dry on sunday
paul that's that's the fact i'll be
coming in wet pulse
ryan garcia right there
i'm good we're not getting the whole
national anthem
we're not getting none of that stuff
see he's
he's getting sponsored by du jour
you got to really
follow how vain we are as a species
that's why
yeah you got to be consistent with the
pause man you can't be out here
willy-nilly with the lingo and don't
throw a pause behind that you know you
never know where my dude's mind is at
man you got yell out pause man
dudes be out here you know thinking
things you gotta shut that down nah bruh
put that back i'm from new york we do
that here pulse ah
let's go let's go we outside all right
so round one here we go we get ready to
start bell's about to ding dang get it
all right everybody right now you take a
step
oh man to see where it be
where b is it for tuna first round he
showed his yellow mouthpiece for doing a
kick in the ground like he's a bull
ready to charge
this is jordan's supercharged ryan right
there he looks ready got the mouthpiece
in white mouthpiece for tuna
revving up like a car or something
he ready to run out though boy all right
round one
fortuna's the southpaw everybody knows
that all right uh ryan garcia is
throwing out a jab he's sticking the jab
and petuna throws the jab under ryan's
red ryan is sticking the jab and for
tuna face tries a short left hook over
the top
and um ryan is throwing the jab for
tuna's blocking he slipped under the
punches
ryan is uh throwing the left hook he's
trying to catch him with a left hook
early
all right oh shoot straight right hand
from uh garcia
all right garcia shoots a straight right
hand that's what's up that's what's up
left hook he's trying to keep him
worried about that left hook he went to
the body with the left hook garcia
and showing good distance showing good
distance i don't like the fact that he's
locking his knees in the middle of the
ring for tuna is moving giving him
angles left and right left and right
showing a lot of footwork uh throws a
right hand a garcia which is blocked
ryan goes back to the jab all right
fortuna goes over the top with his jab
they're back there
all right so left hook by ryan garcia is
partially blocked right hand is
partially blocked by fortuna they're
back in the center of the ring
you see uh garcia and you see
uh fortuna in the center of the ring
fatuna is trying to find the angle
inside but ryan is throwing straight
right hands all right he hits garcia
over the top of the head and he's uh
trying to stalk him all right he catches
garcia with a left hook to the face
garcia backs up for tuna is holding him
and now they got separated they're back
into the center of the ring
hmm straight right hand from garcia
looks very nice straight right hand he
understands what's working he throws it
four times all right he has to go back
to the jab
all right fatuna is uh has ryan garcia
up against ropes ryan is holding they
get separated right now again the
referee warns him for hitting garcia
behind the head
garcia goes back to fainting uh right
hand
and uh he throws the right hand because
that's what he's having the most success
with is the right hand so he's gonna
throw it a lot he's in his own head
right now by throwing that right hand
so much go right back to the jab but he
doesn't all right so you have for tuna
that is uh back in the center of the
ring both of them
jab by ryan ryan is smart shooting a jab
fortuna is dancing moving from left to
right giving them angles again you got
30 seconds in the round
and
uh garcia is landing a lot of right
hands in the first round and he keeps
shooting the right hand because that's
his most successful punch right now
while he did try to land a left hook
right now was unsuccessful
fortuna looks like he's going to land
something and he keeps throwing heavy
shots at garcia garcia backs up doesn't
get hit with those shots
and you have
uh ryan again standing and fortuna just
wants to get out of the first round
and it looks like he is
round one over
i give that to garcia garcia landed a
lot of clean right hands a fatu did land
a couple of good shots like a sweeping
left hook that he did uh land over the
top that got ryan up against the ropes
that made him grab
uh but i see uh how ryan is i'm going to
play this he's using the punches that
actually do connect and actually work
because he's trying to get fatuna
something to think about and something
to to know um danny theriault's in the
room and in there uh stephen a smith
what's going on that's right um
a lot of stuff happening damn king you
way behind me pause oh that's nasty
you're nasty
oh oh that's because
uh you watching it in a different
situation sir i don't know how you
watching it but i'm watching it from
actual uh the zone now
it could be after the situation happened
with the you know we had to connect the
stream and do that other stuff i don't
know
we got a 50 watching right now let's go
so
they're back to jabbing they're back in
the the center of the ring
all right they're both jabbing now
so fatuna has a high guard
and he's throwing punches to ryan's
stomach
he throws oh
left hook by garcia
that's nice for tuna backs up and moves
over to the side he resets and he hits
uh garcia with a jab
fatuna is uh moving from left to right
and he's not stalking anymore
okay
ryan is not throwing any punches but
he's just stalking he's trying to land a
left hook from outside i guess he's
giving him something to think about
other than the right hand for tuna
throws a right hand
and he misses all right so fortuna is
jabbing
all right ryan garcia goes back to his
jab he's high guarding he's jabbing he's
jabbing he's shooting the right hand
he's using exactly what works remember
fortuna is a south paws orion garcia
knows that the right hand works on
southpaws he's throwing the straight
down the pipe he's jabbing and he's
shooting the right hand left hook over
the top from garcia as he shoots the
right hand he's uh measuring fortuna
with the jab
and fortuna catches ryan garcia oh
nice short left hook from garcia
and they they hold they're broken up by
the referee they're back in the center
of the ring
good jab good job by garcia good job by
garcia
he's in the center of the ring
okay they both have high guard right now
and uh garcia ryan went for the left
hook right hand combo it missed
all right and fortuna went for the left
to the face
that missed
remember fatuna is a southpaw so he's in
a long
uh
lock laid a loch need a jab type of
position
and garcia is jabbing
it's pretty good he has a decent
educated jab right now and he's keeping
this guy at his distance he tries to
throw a left hook right hand he's
letting garcia get comfortable for tuna
is all right there's broken up by the
referee
and they're back in the center of the
ring
all right so
garcia is jabbing again you have 30
seconds left in the round
and for tuna is jabbing he's no longer
trying to come inside he pause he shoots
the right hand
and garcia has him uh
reset garcia is stalking him
platoon is fainting
nothing much is happening right now
and garcia tries to land the left hook
from a distance where fatuna easily uh
steps out of the way
and we have a close to round two again
round two went pretty much as much as
round one uh with a lot less right hands
from garcia i give garcia the second
round as well
uh he's starting to get comfortable now
because he's throwing three shots he's
missing all three shots but the fact
that he's throwing three shots means
that he's trying to actually capitalize
on something that he can see inside for
tuna i think fortuna needs to have more
aggression he's having too
little aggression when it comes to this
fight and he needs to step on the gas
and he needs to
uh paralyze um
ryan with fear
he needs to have him overthink that
means he needs to make him hesitate with
uh the shots and he's not doing that
right now
oh what's going on wolf
let me see let me see
he said when i'm getting the zone
contract whenever the zone looks at the
stream it says um i need that guy
all right let's go
never above the bag baby
all right let's go all right so ryan
garcia is throwing the right hand all
right and
all right sharp right hand is coming out
as uh on his repertoire it's really good
see because he towers over for tuna so
he should be able to throw the jabbing
right hand and land him with regularity
but he's not this is this he's he's
absolutely not
so
we got ryan garcia stalking him again
but he's following
he needs to learn how to trap a boxer
and he doesn't know how to trap he's a
counter puncher and he doesn't know how
to stalk and that's the problem and he
has to learn i think he would have
stayed with eddie renault so he would
have learned how to stalk better left
hook over the top from
uh garcia
and fortuna is in a high guard
he throws uh garcia throws a one two
three all three was blocked
as uh fortuna steps away and resets the
whole fight
uh fortuna is jabbing idly in the air
just to give garcia something to think
about
while garcia is trying to set up a right
hand which he does land right there
so the right hand is touching for tuna
and any time fortuna does go to leap in
ryan does a measuring stick with his jab
so one two three and then he does the
four to the body garcia does uh fortuna
back is up against the ropes while uh
now they're in a clinch and the referee
breaks them up
back to the center of the ring
ryan goes right back to stalking for
tuna
and he has uh throws a left hook which
is partially blocked uh garcia
is back in a defensive position as far
as high guard he's using high guard and
shooting right hands through the high
guard in order to frustrate for tuna to
get fortuna to open up open up fortuna
is not doing for tuna is going left to
right uh laterally without actually
moving his feet at the moment right now
pretty decent uh
third round
good right hand from fortuna that
catches ryan garcia off guard i guess he
was setting that up for the last two
rounds
and he's trying to go in and land shots
on garcia but garcia slips all four
shots
in the center of the ring
pretty decent
um
garcia's trying to land the right hand
and he's sticking out the jab for the
left hook
30 seconds left in the fight
20 seconds left in the fight
you have uh garcia still stalking for
tuna
all right i mean in the round i said in
the fight right yeah and around and 10
seconds left
for tuna is surviving yet again
for another round
he's fainting he's jabbing he's fainting
and
round is over
again it's pretty much the same thing
that's happened in the last two rounds
but garcia needs to know learn how to
trap him off so what he needs to do is
he needs to use his lead foot to step on
the outside and shoot a right hand to
guide him into his left hook
what he's doing is when he shoots the
right hand his lead foot is not outside
of fortuna's foot
that's what he needs to establish he
needs to establish
the feet battle first and then shoot the
right hand to bring him into play of the
left hook if that's the the money punch
that he wants to land he needs to learn
how to do so and i don't think they are
teaching them exactly how it's supposed
to be done
yeah great matchup so far that's what's
up
let's see exactly what's going on right
now ryan garcia is up before fortuna
and he really needs to work a little bit
harder on cutting that ring off because
he's not cutting the ring off like he's
supposed to just this
this level of the game you're supposed
to be able to cut the ring off and he's
not
ryan can't go into stalker mode because
he's too busy being a counter puncher
he's a boxer counter puncher
and he's has to take the lead right now
and get for tuna and i think that is
frustrating him in some form or fashion
right now because he i guess he expected
for tuna to attack him and fortuna is
not attacking him in the manner that he
wants him to attack him all right so we
have
right now
uh fortuna
actually uh throwing the jab
ryan garcia
actually shooting a jab over the top
high guard
nothing is being land from patuna to be
honest with you he's resetting
and
they need to actually mix it up a little
bit more ryan garcia is trying to land
the right hand and garcia
uh throws a right to the body left hook
that actually lands
right hand
right now all right so now he catches
for tuna and fortuna catches him back
because ryan started to open up because
he thought he had fortuna
all right so he's throwing the right
hand through his guard
and he's catching he has for tune up
against the ropes the right hand is
breaking fortuna's guard
and and he throws a left hook to the
body and drops for tuna he drops petuna
with a left hook to the body which is a
nice shot
he set him up pretty well for tuna is
taking it he spit his mouthpiece out to
give himself more time
smart move veteran move
smart move veteran move
that was a nice body shot definitely
something good
he told him watch it referee they're
back in the middle of the ring with a
minute 23 left
um for tuna ryan
immediately goes back to the to the body
fatuna is moving
garcia is uh standing there he's not
exactly tacking
uh fortuna is fainting moving from left
to right hands down to his waist
and he's moving he's trying to throw a
one two three
uh he's giving uh garcia something to
hit but garcia is actually not doing
anything um fatuna actually is doing
more of the work right now ever since he
got dropped with his hands down to his
waist coming at garcia's very unorthodox
right now
when he's doing this for tuna is and
garcia now puts his jab up and puts his
hands and his guard up actually to start
for tuna but fatuna is actually fighting
with his hands down to his waist to be
honest with you pass his boxing line on
his shorts
all right so fortuna is moving from left
to right and garcia is jabbing trying to
land a left hook
and is uh 20 seconds left in the round
and garcia goes back to the left to the
body
and fortuna catches garcia with a
straight right
left hook from garcia and right hand
left hook from garcia garcia speed is
actually becoming a factor in this round
and i think actually garcia has actually
established itself as a dominant factor
in this round
uh so the left hook to the body was
beautifully delivered
uh by disguising it from the right hand
the right hand and then he slid inside
and threw the left to the lever court
for tuna and we got devin haney at the
fight right now
this is the stuff
that
fight gods do
they go and they sit there
at your fight and they tell you i want
you next
beautiful stuff to see devin haney there
left hook beautiful to the body of
fortuna didn't see it coming dropped him
a delayed shot
let me see let me see
down goes anime i'm not only a podcaster
i'm a member of community i love
watching the shows as much as i love
being on them that's what's up
what's up skiing i know nothing about
boxing analysts but i enjoy your
commentary thank you so much chosen one
i appreciate that so much
try very hard all right so they're back
in the center of the ring uh ryan garcia
is throwing jabs and right hands ryan
garcia is warmed up now and this is what
i was talking about if he was warm from
the round one we could have got this
from round one also uh fortuna is
actually out there meeting him uh head
on high guard
and shorter guy
uh probably uh weighs less than garcia
and he in the speed realm i think garcia
is light years ahead of him
so ryan is throwing left hooks and right
hands he's being
more of ryan garcia this is what i
expected to see from him
this right here this is exactly what
he's supposed to be doing all right so
petunia throws uh right hand over the
top
and garcia throws a straight jab i mean
right hand down the middle
nice
right hand
straight down the middle
all right here we go um for tuna is
eating right hands from garcia garcia
understands that the left to the body
will come later if he keeps landing the
straight right hands oh fortuna catches
him and
he get caught by another
left hook from ryan garcia and down goes
for tuna
very fast very quick
it was it was it was a shadow punch that
i didn't see coming
for tuna didn't either so when fortuna
gets hurt he puts his hands down low and
he's swinging he goes for broke i like
this dude uh i think fertility is a
great measuring stick to ryan garcia
and this is good this is something good
that can happen ryan garcia is throwing
right hands and left hooks and he's he's
missing the left hook the the left hook
is missing
by
miller inches
if that's the thing that's a measurement
right
okay straight right hand oh he catches
ryan garcia with a left hook ryan garcia
stumbles back
beautiful shot
i said left hook is right that's right
hook sorry he's a southpaw my bad
all right garcia uh catches his balance
and throws a one two he goes right back
to the right hand
ryan garcia's uh
what is it his left ear is red from
fortuna landing that shot and he goes
back to landing stiff straight right
hands nice jab from garcia garcia slowed
down his pace a little bit after that
shot that he took
he's still stalking for tuna
but fortuna's moving from side to side
we got 23 seconds left in the round
and we have garcia doing exactly what
he's supposed to do
jab and get for tuna into position he
should he should slide up on him put his
left foot on the outside of fortuna and
shoot the right hand to keep him in
position freeze them in place and
through the left of the body but he's
not doing so
and this is what i would tell him to do
nice jab round is over
drop for tuna again
another 10-8 round uh
right now fortuna is down huge he's down
um
every round he lost to be honest with
you in
two of those rounds he lost by two
points so it's very very very tenuous
right now for fortuna
let me see
thank you thank you thank you
yo
you could tell bk
that he is in his bag
how he's moving his hands like like i i
love when a boxer throws a punch and
they do this you understand they they
feel it they feel it within his body you
see when his confidence is at his
highest
how garcia swag is
and that's when he's not in his head
that's what i tell you i want him out of
his head paul's i want him to
actually fight
without thinking
all right so here we go
so right now
there's a lot of cap going on with these
uh announces uh fortuna came out
charging that garcia he's trying to back
garcia up right now this is round six
and garcia is standing in his ground
throwing a jab and he left hook and he
drops for tuna now i told you ryan
garcia is a natural counterpuncher
fortuna attacked him and he spits out
his mouthpiece again fight is over
that's it sixth round garcia knockout uh
soon as fortuna
attacked ryan garcia was able to stand
his ground throw a one-two and throw
that three over the top that left hook
was exactly what he was trying to land
but being that he is not an actual
stalker he is a counter puncher boxer
because he wants you to come to him so
he can give you his offense that's when
he actually exploded and showed you
excuse me
exactly everything that he had to offer
that was exactly what i wanted to see
from him
that's what i needed to see from fortuna
pushed him in certain areas that he
wasn't comfortable in and i think ryan
needs to get out of his head i think
this is the confidence builder that he
needs to go and take one of those big
fights um is he is he ready for somebody
like tank i don't think so is he ready
for somebody like devin haney i don't
think devin haney punches hard enough to
keep uh
uh garcia off of him but
at the same time i think devin haney is
slick enough to actually
uh make garcia
have pause you know um to to not have
trepidation and acts and trying to stalk
uh devin haney shakur stevenson if he
was to go up to garcia's weight class i
think he would dominate garcia i think
uh garcia does have the ability to uh
make it a really good fight
but
um to be honest with you i i give that
was see
when
he landed that one two three
like i said
when futuna actually decided
to push the the narrative forward
um
that was a terrific fight
i gotta say thank you
all 50 people for showing up you know i
think we had with the highest we had 60
people in here that was dope uh
listen again
75 likes share it out send it to
everybody let me see who else is in
there happy character that's awesome i'm
happy to have come across the community
thank you man that's what's up thank you
thank you for uh
for even rocking with me man and into
doing this with my passion but
understand us at iop
everything we're going to do we're going
to try to do it at the highest level
soon you guys are going to be able to
call in
like i said y'all could hit the cash app
uh
if y'all want to you know you know hit
off a little donation or whatever you
want to do that's what's up um
but the call-in feature is gonna be lit
you guys are gonna be able to call and
we're gonna be able to interact
uh i know we had a little hiccup earlier
we got right back to it and just like uh
true boxes we get knocked down we get up
and we give back everything that we were
trying to accomplish um
yeah now everything else ryan garcia is
about to do his cap you know you're
gonna be calling out people who's gonna
be telling people that he conquered the
universe but this was a huge stepping
stone in his future um
yo we're going to be definitely covering
the jake paul fight uh hassim rockmon jr
fight we have uh jamal charlo we have a
couple of fights uh coming up so
remember saturday's 10 p.m the king goes
in
uh combat talk with the king new merch
coming to the ilp store so you know hit
the t spring up we're gonna have new
merch there see y'all tomorrow 1pm ilp
i got a lot of smoke man
y'all gonna like this one you're gonna
like this iop that's crazy but god bless
good night everybody stay safe uh if
you're drinking don't drive
all right understand if you're drinking
don't drive have a designated driver at
all times all right i'm drinking in the
safety of my home i'm not going outside
uh so listen if you're drinking don't
drive all right
please practice safety at all times god
bless i want to see y'all all tomorrow
ilp y'all have a great night man thank
y'all for